[Music]
hello and welcome to a week seven
Edition the Beacher report fantasy
football show presented by State Farm my
name is Adam Levitan of establish
run.com as always joined by Michael
Leone of establish the run.com as we get
set for a by Laden week seven also an
injury Laden week seven big mess out
there for people in season long leagues
Leone how's it going
today it's going pretty well I've got a
team that's just absolutely ravaged by
by weeks but we we proceed yes that's
why we are here to talk through some
ideas for people on BI weeks and we did
have a ton ton ton of injuries last week
are which is going to lead to some
options off the wire and stuff like that
which we can talk about here as we move
along hope everyone is having a great
week here to topic of today's show is
players that you can add players that
you can trade for players that should be
on your
team for the stretch run and maybe it's
not the stretch run yet maybe I'm
exaggerating it's not the stretch run
yet
however will be soon we want to get our
rosters in good shape so we're going to
go over six guys here that we think are
going to be assets down the stretch
heading into the fantasy playoffs for
your fantasy team the first one that we
wanted to talk about is puka nkua now I
understand puka Nika did not have a
great game last week I understand Cooper
cup is back I get all that I understand
pukaa was a fifth round pick somewhat
unheralded but I think people fail to
realize is that puk's Target share is
going to be massive because this team is
going to be very very tight in who they
throw the ball to they only play three
wide receivers they only play one tight
end
puka I think can get 25% of targets even
with Cooper cup out there going forward
and with kyen Williams out I think this
team is going to be pretty Thro heavy
the rest of the way so I feel like right
now coming off this bad game that puka
had combined with Cooper Cup's return
people are p right now interesting time
to trade for puka here Leone what kind
of stuff do you think maybe you would
give up to get puka and what do you
think about his Outlook rest of
way yeah I mean I'm pretty optimistic on
puka rest of way as you mentioned with
the target share it's actually been like
just south of 30% the two games with
Cooper cup it's one of those situations
where I think people be like look at the
production and think okay Cooper Cup's
back so we're done with puka but really
that's not what happened they just ran
an abnormally low amount of plays last
game and it's really all the targets are
being funnel the Cooper cup and puka AA
Cooper cup makes the offense run more so
I'm really optimistic about puka the
rest of the way like I think I'd trade
someone like Tyler Lockett for puka akua
um where you know little bit more name
recognition on lock it someone might be
thinking they're selling you know high
on puka nakua I think that's the type of
move that makes a lot of sense to make
oh for sure and yeah we still have pauka
in the top 30 we do a rest of season top
150 rankings every week to try to help
people with trades and rest of season
value which bakes in buys and injuries
and all that and we still have pauka in
our top 30 feel pretty good about that
second guy that I think maybe you can
buy low on right now is Devon Smith now
dvon Smith had an awesome year last year
in part because he was able to earn the
same amount of targets that AJ Brown
earned it hasn't gone that way this year
Devonte Smith has been well behind AJ
Brown in Target share the question is is
that sticky the of the season now
Devonte Smith I think is a little bit
worse than AJ Brown of just an actual
real life NFL player so I do expect AJ
Brown to earn more targets than Devonte
but maybe not at the same rate he has
been so far this
year interesting spot here going forward
for devant Smith Leon and by the way we
should know they did add Julio Jones I
am I haven't even talked to you about
this I was curious what you thought
about the addition of Julio Jones and if
you think season long people should be
adding him at all so may maybe you can
answer that as well as Devon Smith
stuff yeah with Smith I think he's your
classic by low we actually have him on
the established to run by Leone model
for the week which basically says that
based on his current usage he should be
scoring more fantasy points per game
than he is and is likely to moving
forward and that's not even accounting
for the fact that you know he could see
his Target share come up even higher
than it's been given how close he was
with AJ Brown last year so definitely
digging Devon as a buy low as far as who
IO I don't really think he's an ad I
just think at this point in his career
he's really just going to be a role guy
he might be more useful especially in
certain packages and situations than you
know the third wide receiver they're
rolling out now whether it's quz Watkins
or Hami so I think it's more just a role
player right now the upside isn't gonna
match what people associate with Julio
Jones yeah I'd add two things first the
Eagles Fantasy Playoff schedule is
outrageously soft week 15 16 17 they
have very very good match match up some
of the best in the league on Julio been
on the street 34 years old last time we
saw him I mean just could not stay on
the field could only play situationally
for the Titans it's pretty skeptical
that Julio is gonna have an impact here
for the
Eagles keep it moveing to the Bears
backfield here and we'll go with Roshan
Johnson
now Roshan man I was excited about
Roshan back up to beon
uh at the University of Texas never
really got to show what he could do
there but strikes me as a really
talented guy C Herbert has a high ankle
spring which is an awful injury for NFL
running back he could be out a really
long time they don't really seem to like
Deontay Foreman they don't really seem
to love Travis Homer and so there's no
reason not given the state of their team
to just load Roshan Johnson up right now
he's still in the concussion protocol
this week but man if he's on waivers I
think he should be added
what do you think about bearss backfield
rest of season Le only because there's a
lot of moving Parts here I mean Fields
could be done he dislocated throwing
thumb you don't know how long Fields is
going to be out for and then obviously
the Bears are incentivized to lose games
big time right now so it's a bit of a
tricky situation what do you think about
bears backfield rest of season yeah I
mean I think it's you know one of those
classic spots to lean into the
uncertainty of the situation you've
mentioned a lot of question marks and
along with those people are going to be
fearful of anybody on that team
especially a running back that's been
injured the last couple weeks and
doesn't have any sort of track record in
Roshan Johnson but definitely has the
most upside of these backs behind CLE
Herbert mean you the usage for deont
Foreman last week wasn't that great we
had darant T Evans even mixing in a bit
more playing 36% of the snap so I think
that just shows they don't have faith in
deont foran and once Roshan Johnson's
back in healthy this could really be his
backfield he actually had a pretty good
Target share in limited playing time and
those high value touches are important
so he's someone you can acquire really
cheaply you know maybe can trade a James
Conor type for him or a Jaylen Warren
one of the Pittsburgh running backs and
get a bit more upside uh again with the
uncertainty of the situation in Chicago
yeah I agreed and I I just think
Roshan's talented right more talented
than a normal fourth round NFL running
back all right take a pause there on the
by low types and we'll head to some of
your chat questions now I appreciate all
of you in chat sing in your questions we
of course are here for the people you
know we're here to answer your questions
help your team first question from Korn
says should I trade Jacobs Josh Jacobs
and Travis etn for Tyreek Hill so to me
this is one that's hard to answer
without knowing your team and I
absolutely love Tyreek Hill but my God
this is a lot to give up Leone Josh
Jacob's usage is outrageous Travis etn
usage is outrageous obviously Tyreek
Hill is an incredible incredible fantasy
asset to have what would you rather
which side would you rather have here
the running back side or the Tyreek hill
side I mean I think if you've got
starting running backs uh that you can
plug in then that that are pretty good
I'd take the Tyreek Hill Side just
because he's such a unique player um
it's less value but it could be one of
those situations you really optimize
your starting lineup but yeah it's tough
to answer without without total context
we got another question you know trade
CMC for Josh Jacobs and Devonte Adams
and it's the same sort of thing it
really depends you know what type of
League you're in and and who the guys
that you'd be starting in a two for one
type trade but ultimately I think I mean
it's tough we have CMC and Tyreek as the
one and two players overall rest of the
season I don't think that's surprising
anybody consensus wise I really still
like Devonte Adams I'm a bit of a
Devonte Adams bull I it's investing a
lot in the Raiders to trade the number
one overall player for two guys on the
Raiders but if you're struggling for
depth it seems like a fine move to make
like you're getting two borderline first
round assets for CMC but if you have no
depth issues you've got the number one
overall player in fantasy he's the guy
that can just straight out win you weeks
come the playoff time and I just write
it out with CMC yeah I do want to be
clear that Josh Jacobs is going to be
better right like Josh Jacob's usage is
so good and so strong and he's a
talented guy like his results will be
better will be more in line with his
opportunity and he has some of the best
opportunity in the entire NFL right now
so yeah I don't want to like be selling
low on Josh Jacobs now just because he's
struggled with actual production so far
so yeah that it's tougher for me to give
up such strong assets but as we get to
the playoffs as once we get out of the
by weeks get away from some of these
injury monsoons you're GNA want to have
the best players for the playoffs and
that's what Leone is saying like having
Christian mcaffry for the playoffs is
just a total smash um chaye says should
I give up Maris Brown to get gavon
Williams
I don't know man I have not liked what
I've seen from Javon Williams this year
there Jalil mcglauflin has arguably
outplayed him and now they have three
guys in this back field and I know P
Ryan's pretty much only playing back uh
passing down stuff but still the state
of this team would not suggest that they
should be pushing Javonte Williams into
more workload either so I'm not that
excited about jvonte Williams right now
that said the mares brown stuff is not
that exciting either considering his
quarterback as Josh dos so what do you
think got that one Leone who' you rather
have Maris brown or gavon Williams I'd
rather have Maris Brown I think you know
with Kyler Murray practicing and
hopefully getting back sometime soon for
the Cardinals there's some real upside
for Maris Brown end of season whereas
gavonte Williams you know we're always
concerned about the return from injury
and now with Julio mcclaflin playing
really well it seems like he's gonna mix
in the team's not that good and I just
think it's just going to be a lot of
empty volume for gavonte Williams I'll
take the high Target share wide receiver
who could get a big upgrade at
quarterback come play off time so that's
the one I like we got another question
from Chargers all day should I sell high
on leaport that's Sam laporta for the
Detroit Lions I tweeted this out the
other day but in my expected fantasy
points per game metric which just kind
of looks at you know Red Zone targets
for a player air yards total targets and
different usage metrics and tries to
slap on how many fantasy points they'll
score we've got Sam leaport a third
overall on the season at the tight end
position so I really don't think you
should sell High he's top five in our
rest of season won 50 rankings over at
established the Run he's also someone
that from an efficiency standpoint is
probably gonna outperform his expected
fantasy points per game so everything
looks good for leor I just don't
realistically know what you would get
for him in a sell High unless you just
don't need tight end at all right I mean
that's really the question is what who's
your other tight end because you can't
really sell a port if you don't have any
other tight end he's such a Difference
Maker their big time the only other
point I want to make on on Maris Brown
is the trade deadline is I believe
October 31st and so there's like some
chance that Maris Brown is dealt to the
deadline it's not zero I don't think
it's high but there's some chance
because Maris bran is in the final year
of his rookie contract obviously the
Cardinals would rather get something for
him or should be wanting to get
something for him rather than letting
him walk in free agency after this year
as they rebuild all
right let's go to the bundles presented
by our friend at State Farm These are
quarterback pass catcher Duos that we
like for this week any you guys who play
DFS that's kind of our specialty over at
establish the run you want to be
stacking when you're playing DFS
tournaments reduce the number of things
you have to get right and increase the
correlation and upside in your lineups
if your quarterback goes off chances are
your pass catcher or at least one pass
catcher on that team is also going to
outperform
expectation start with the giant stuff
so we don't know who's going to start
yet between Tyrod Taylor and Daniel
Jones I think it will end up being Tyrod
Taylor I'm not sure but him to Darren
Waller is really interesting this week
because they're playing Washington and
my God this Washington defense this
Washington secondary has just been
getting absolutely torched by opposing
passing games I understand the Giants
are not exciting but this is a major
major spot for them to actually show
some efficiency on the Giants and I
still think Darren Waller can play man
like I understand it hasn't been great
for him as a giant so far but I do think
the guy can still play and he is by far
their best pass catching option so Tyrod
Taylor if he starts if not Daniel dimes
to Darren Waller here Leon any thoughts
on that one then you can go to the next
one yeah I mean I would just add to your
point like how bad Washington's defense
has been overall averaging uh 7.2 yards
per pass attempt allowed we've seen them
give up big games to bad teams too right
like not just good teams it was Atlanta
last week I was on the show afraid to
play Kyle Pitts should have been afraid
to play Kyle pittz and it was against
Justin fields in Chicago the week before
so um yeah it's definitely a good spot
for the Giants pass game our number two
one is Gino Smith to DK metf meta's been
pretty disappointing this season I know
working on our projections for weekly
it's hard to even get them to separate
from Tyler Lockett but I do think for
you know on a team level Seattle's in a
pretty good spot this week against
Arizona Seattle hasn't run a lot of
plays per game this year which is one of
those little things you look at a lot
but they're averaging only 61 plays per
game teams against Arizona are averaging
like 66 plays per game and I think that
you know the team total is obviously a
lot higher in a favorable matchup so I
think it's a good spot for both the
efficiency and the volume to improve for
the P game for Seattle yeah major
breakout spot here for Seattle and
that's why we wanted to highlight that
one not because DK mcha is like some
awesome awesome awesome play in a vacuum
but if Gino Smith is able to find major
success here against Arizona which we
think he will he'll likely bring along
DK meaf Lockett or jsn with him still
think mchf is the best natural Talent
there third bundle Jordan love and
Christian Watson now we have not seen
these guys in a while because they
played uh two weeks ago then they had
the buy but Christian Watson looked very
healthy in that game before the buy and
now they get the Broncos and I mean I
understand that the Broncos defense
looked reasonable against the Chiefs I
don't know that that's sustainable given
the talent that they have on this
defense Jordan love gets a long week to
get ready he looked so bad in that game
against the Raiders think he'll bounce
back here and chrisan Watson when he
hits hits in such a big way and he's
more likely to do so against the Broncos
so Jordan love and Christian Watson has
major major upside the floor is probably
lower than some of these other ones that
we're going to talk about but major
upside on Jordan love and Christian
Watson this week I
think Leon to number four yeah Watson
was just notes like a pretty good Buy
Low option in general I think now is
probably the time to do it before this
awesome matchup against Denver because
if he explodes the price tag is going to
go way up but yeah our fourth bundle is
Patrick Mahomes to Travis Kelce against
the Chargers know you feel a little
silly including this one in the bundle
because it's you know obvious starts
each week but I do think the expectation
for both these guys is a bit higher than
normal Chargers game last week
disappointed a little bit but you know
the same things hold true that I said
last week they're really uptempo team
they throw a lot this spreads a little
bit tighter for Kansas City than it
normally is and they're a team that runs
a lot of plays obviously they are year
in and year out top three in the NFL and
pass right over expectation so just the
volume of pass attempts has a chance to
be really huge here yeah I thought that
people were somewhat panicked on Chiefs
offense I mean they only scored one
touchdown against the Broncos you know
and they they were struggling just to
move the ball against the Broncos so I I
just wanted to point out that this is a
really good spot for the Chiefs here in
this game against the Chargers so many
potential
plays last bundle of course presented by
State Farm is the 49ers stuff now 49ers
stuff was bad last week you can chalk
that up I think to how good this
Cleveland defense is now they get a home
game against Minnesota Debo is banged up
Christian mcaffry is banged up the
cleanest stack is Brock pie to Brandon
auk and so that's the fifth bundle he p
to auk expecting a big time bounce back
and man I've long been a Debo hater and
auk lover and I feel like this is a
really good spot for auk to get loose
here I will say though Leone Minnesota's
defense has been better than I expected
all year so this isn't like a home run
matchup but I think it's a really good
one any thoughts on that one before we
get back to some chat
questions yeah I I think it's a really
good spot we've got iuk as a top 10 wide
receiver on the week wouldn't be
surprised if San Francisco through a
little bit more than usual even being
seven-point favorites uh with CMC banged
up we'll kind of see if he goes or not
also like being in a domes an upgrade
for San Francisco and IU someone I know
we've taken his over in props a couple
weeks in a row and it's been pretty
tight but the volume and the targets
have been there uh the efficiency hasn't
been as strong the last two weeks as it
was out of the gate but this is a guy
that can rack up chunk plays in an
absolute
hurry all right let's get to some of
your chat questions now first question
from John ler says who should I be
asking for from Trading away Kenneth
Walker well listen uh we're pretty high
on Kenneth Walker we have Kenneth Walker
17th overall in our rest of season top
150 rankings I would be asking for a lot
I mean I would be asking for Tony Pard
uh bejan Robinson Travis etn Josh Jacobs
Aman Ross Brown Devonte Adams CD l I
mean these are the kind of players that
I would consider to be in the same range
as Kenneth Walker at this point even
coming out of the buy he did not seed
much if any work any valuable work to
Zack shanet whatsoever so yeah I don't
know man I don't think I'd be wanting to
really trade Kenneth Walker Le you get
something really really awesome Leon
next question from gobin Dugan says who
should I get for Michael Thomas that's a
harder sell Leone because Michael Thomas
hasn't really had a single Breakout game
all year he's been fine but has not had
a Breakout game all year what do you
think about what can you get for Michael
Thomas at this point yeah I mean that
does make it difficult to answer some
guys we have ranked you know closely to
Michael Thomas but ahead of him include
you know other slow starters at wide
receiver Deontay Johnson Jerry Judy
where people might be down on them or
you know sick of the the injury return
table for Deontay Johnson and that might
be an opportunity I do think at running
back Jamir Gibbs who we talked about
last week if you can get him now is the
time it might be tough with deont banged
up and injured but Montgomery injury
aside the big plays for Gibbs are going
to come eventually and this offense this
team is rolling right now for Detroit so
maybe Michael Thomas plus a little
something get you Jamir Gibbs that's a
pretty good
opportunity last question here before we
get back to the buy Lowe's from comes
from Cole pervis he says Rasheed rice
sleeper start or Calvin Ridley tonight
so I don't think you can bench Calvin
Ridley for Rashid rice right like I
don't think you can do that even though
I expect Marshon Latimore to see a lot
of Cal Ridley tonight I'm still starting
Cal Ridley however Leone however I do
not want to poo poo Rashid rice because
to me he is a guy that you should have
on your team going forward I understand
they just got micole Hardman I don't
think that's really gonna affect Rashid
Rice's role too much if he can just get
60 or 70% of the routes with Justin
Watson out I think Rashid Rice's is
gonna be really really productive so I'm
starting C really tonight but definitely
happy to have Rashid rice on my team oh
speaking of Rashid rice as we get back
to the by Low's Leon our fourth is
actually rasheid rice so I don't rehash
what I just said but yeah any further
thoughts on Rashid rice as our fourth
player to trade for here what a what a
segue set up by producer Ian with the
with the Rashid rice by by low at number
four here but his routes were up he said
a season high in routes week six now
you've got the Watson injury and I think
the Hardman trade is more you know an
indictment of the depth at wide receiver
behind rice like they didn't expect to
have to play rice but you've got Watson
hurt you've got Sky Moore mvs out there
running routes and earning no targets
not performing whatsoever so yeah I do
think we kind of got like a mini
breakout from rice but there's still
potential for a lot more so I do like
trying to acquire him
now fifth guy to trade for right now is
Jonathan Taylor and this is a difficult
one I think to execute because people
have been probably waiting and waiting
and waiting for Jonathan Taylor maybe
they want to keep waiting but even last
week we saw Zack Moss basically even
with Jonathan Taylor in terms of usage
will that be sticky I don't think so I
also think that it's a bit
counterintuitive but I do think Gardner
mshu is a better quarterback for
Jonathan Taylor production than Anthony
Richardson because mchu will throw more
to the running back we saw 13 Targets in
the running back position last week from
Gardner muu and you don't get the tush
push you don't get the goal line runs
you don't get the red zone runs like you
would have had from Anthony Richardson
under Gardner mchu so if anyone out
there is frustrated with Jonathan Taylor
right now maybe they took him in round
two or round three and they're one and
five right now I'd be trying to inquire
Jonathan Taylor any thoughts on that one
Leon then you can go to our final one
yeah I think anytime you know a player
is really talented and you can grab them
at a discount it makes sense like you
you take on the uncertainty the reward
is generally worth the risk in those
situations that's true for Tor and we're
thinking like we're really focused on
upside so if you look at Z flowers as
our number six guy here for Baltimore
it's another play for upside where there
might be other wide receivers ranked
similarly like you know Adam Thelen who
are going to be more consistent in terms
of targets right now but we've seen
historically that rookie wide receivers
are the types of players that can win
your win you year league over the second
half of the season and they always kind
of uptick over the second half of the
season so for Z flowers to have already
carved out this number one role for
Baltimore I think it's huge I think the
Baltimore offense in general is going to
score a lot more touchdowns the second
half of the Season than they have thus
far and z in particular could really
benefit there see his efficiency Spike I
don't think people realize I mean z
flower is immediately and has sustained
the number one role like he has been
earning targets and League best among
the league leaders at earning targets
and people like oh but OD Odell Beckham
hasn't been good in five years guys
Rashad baitman has never been good in
the NFL with all due respect so you know
Z flowers right now is actually so
clearcut the number one they've even run
Nelson aalor as their number two for
much of this season because baitman and
Odell have been struggling so
badly all right let's recap the list
here six players to trade for right now
that we think you should be trading for
right now puka nakua Devon Smith the
slim Reaper Roshan Johnson Rashi rice JT
Jonathan Taylor and Z flowers yes Z
flowers not Odell Beck all right let's
get some more questions here get to as
many as we can quickly Colt says sequan
and Higgins for Jonathan Taylor and
Calvin Ridley I like getting out from
under saquan Barkley here Leone and also
T Higgins has been a mess so I like the
JT Ridley side of that one what do you
think about saquan Higgins for JT and
Ridley yeah I think it's one of those
trades that's very close on the surface
but the upside really tilts the way of
JT Ridley and the risk side tilts the
way of Quan higen so give me JT and
Ridley yeah I mean I'm worried about for
sure uh R Lopez says Julio Jones worth
it we already talked about that one a
little bit earlier in the show are Lopez
just to recap we don't think that
there's much chance for Julio to earn
anything more than number three
rotational role and that's not gonna be
a very voluminous role and last time we
saw him he couldn't even stay healthy
and was not even that effective when he
was on the field so I don't think I'd be
dropping anyone that you like for Julio
Jones Andy says Calvin Ridley or
Christian Watson this week so we have
Cal reallyy tonight against Marshon
ladimore we already talked about the
spot this week for Christian Watson
which is very good against the Broncos
what do you think about that one Leone
straight up Ridley or Christian Watson
this week I think I I'll slide the way
of Christian Watson we've got a pretty
gross game total tonight for Ridley in
this Jags Saints game I don't mind
Ridley I think he's a fine start but I'd
probably lean the upside against the
horrific Denver defense and the big
playability of Christian Watson and
that's how our projection that
established to run have it have those
guys pretty close in base projection but
then when you start to look at the
ceiling projection Watson starts to pull
away from Calvin
Ridley Shannon says would you trade DK
Henry for Josh Jacobs would you trade
Derek Henry for Josh Jacobs now there's
problems in Tennessee Ryan tanah is hurt
their backups are very shaky NFL
players um derck Henry needs to score
touchdowns and when you have Malik
Willis or will Levis in there you're
less likely to score touchdowns so I
prefer Josh Jacobs to King Henry any
dispute there
Leone no I'm with you I've got uh
Jacob's ahead of Henry as well cash
gotta go asks is trading for Jefferson
worth the risk at this point you've
really got to assess your team and
figure out like how many teams make the
playoffs the odds are you making the
playoffs can you afford to take some
zero weeks from from Justin Jefferson
for a little while here but but I do
like the idea of taking on that risk for
a potential super team come playoff time
like that's when I want my team to Peak
so yeah I definitely think it can be
worth the risk to trade for Justin
Jefferson just don't do it if you're you
know if you're 500 record-wise and you
might not make the playoffs then then
it's not worth the risk but if you're
feeling pretty good about just making
the playoffs I'm all about optimizing
your team for when the playoffs start
I've heard about some of these leagues
where like eight out of 12 teams make
the playoffs I just want to be on the
record here that that's unamerican but I
also say if you're in a league where
eight out of 12 teams make the playoffs
you can be doing stuff like trading for
Justin Jefferson right now don't expect
him back though for like another month
Miller says it's Cooper cup for alve and
JT a good trade I I don't want to give
up Cooper cup man I I want Cooper Cup on
my team he looks exactly like he did two
years ago when he set the record when he
broke like every receiving record so I
think I want Cup on my team here I
understand the appeal of alve and JT I
like both those guys but it's really
hard for me to pull the trigger on cup
here what do you think about that one
Leon then you can move to the next one
I'm with you 100% Cooper Cup right now
we got to act fast we've got enough
there we were on him last week is kind
of like a buy high again uh the price is
just going to go up and up after each
and every week that he plays next
question from crispy crisp trade away
Jonathan tayor to receive Jaylen Wadd
we've got Jonathan Tor 28th in our rest
of season rankings and Wadd for 41st
overall personally I probably have it a
little bit closer just because I'm
really in on this Dolphins offense and I
do think that if anything happened to
Tyreek Hill wad would just be such you
know a huge League winner down the
stretch so I think it's a little bit
closer than our ranks have it uh so some
of that just comes down to how you're
feeling positionally um but you know I'd
probably side JT's way but I think it's
pretty close one yeah agree I think JT
there uh for me cash gotta go gets
another question in WoW wow how rich
cash got to go uh how much lower is
Kiren Williams value right now I think
the question is a how severe is ky
Williams ankle latest news is that he
could be out through their week 10 buy
which obviously stinks um and second
when he comes back will he have the same
role that he had so the latter question
I think yes like these guys they added
darell Henderson uh Roy Freeman Zack
Evans they're not gonna I think they're
like obsessed with kyn so assuming KY
can get back healthy I think he'll have
his role so I'm not too too too worried
about kyn if you have an injured spot
and you're able to get by for the next
three four weeks without him uh I'd
rather have him last question Leone
Jordan Addison or Christian Kirk who do
you like better this week Jordan Addison
or Christian
Kirk we've got this one Incredibly Close
I mean it's not a very good matchup for
either Addison or Kirk the team totals
for Jacksonville and Minnesota are bit
lower than they would normally be with Z
Jones out you know I think Kirk's the
Flor play Addison's the ceiling play I
hate that that's such a cop out but I'd
kind of consider if you're a big
Underdog in your matchup if you're a
favorite if you're a favorite I'd go
with Christian Kirk especially in a PP
full PPR format he's gonna see more
targets most likely than Jordan Addison
much safer floor but Addison we've
already seen him hit on some big plays
this year and there's also a little bit
more uncertainty with Justin Jefferson
out we only have a one game sample was
kind of like a a weird game Flow last
week against Chicago so uh the upside
lends its way towards Addison so that's
the guy I'd play if you're a big
dog all right we've set it all ahead of
week seven fantasy football appreciate
you being here for the leacha report
fanty football show presented by State
Farm if you're interested in more
in-depth content about fantasy football
you can always check us out at establish
we do have a free podcast and a free
YouTube channel if you search establish
the run you should be able to find that
for everyone behind the scenes at
Bleacher Report everyone behind the
scenes at establish the Run appreciate
you all we'll see you next week for
weekend